slightly different terms introducing an initialized workspace system is a valid Channel That's because tensoring a fixed
density Matrix to a given density Matrix always gives us a density Matrix and it's a linear mapping by the bilinearity
of tensor products unitary operations are always valid channels as I discussed earlier in the lesson tracing out a system is a valid Channel because the
partial Trace is a linear mapping that always transforms density matrices into density matrices and finally compositions of
channels are always channels which is quite simple but definitely worth observing in its own right and with the
four implications we just covered we've established the equivalence of our three Channel representations along with the
original definition of a channel in particular we started with the definition of a channel we saw how that definition implies that its Cho
representation necessarily satisfies two basic conditions then we we saw how those conditions allow us to find a Krauss representation which in turn
allows us to find a Stein spring representation and finally we saw that the existance of a Stein spring representation reveals that we do in
fact have a valid channel of course there are technical details in there and it's not necessarily simple especially
when you're seeing it for the first time but what's interesting and noteworthy here is that these implications are set up in a way that does in fact make
things as easy as possible and in mathematics you should never feel feel any shame in taking the easy way out for
example it's not at all obvious that every channel has a Stein spring representation or a crow representation
but it is relatively easy to conclude that the Choy representation of every channel satisfies the two conditions that we've associated with it and that
allows us to follow a more or less algebraic path to the other two representations in a similar vein the
last implication from a Stein spring representation back to the definition is also relatively straightforward and it
allows us to conclude that we only get channels and no other mappings from Choy representations assuming that the
required conditions are met and as I alluded to before the way that we argue these implications are sufficiently mechanical to allow us to easily convert
between the representations and if you go back to some of the examples that we covered earlier in the lesson you'll find that it is in fact possible to
convert between the representations sometimes quite easily and directly and that is the end of the
lesson which has been all about channels we talked about what they are and we took a look at some basic examples we discussed three ways that channels can
be represented and we dove into some technical details that establish the equivalence of these representations I
hope you'll join me for the next lesson which is all about measurements in the general formulation of quantum information goodbye until then